c'est quand je sais parler depuis
quelques jours ça s'est passé dans
l'émission planète rap diffusée sur
skyrock dans l'émission the reçu un
rappeur est tout de suite l'ambiance est
devenue très bizarre déjà il est arrivé
en peignoir il ya surtout proposer de
l'alcool animateurs fred musa j'aime
beaucoup des lions est ainsi cohabiter
avant de sortir ensuite un énorme besoin
que fred musa a fumé lors de l'émission
qui était retransmise en direct à la
radio
alors tout le monde en a parlé et ce nom
nous attendre nos informations c'est aux
mondiaux salvat est en réalité un
comédien est plus un comédien cas
rappeur regarder ça et tu arrives libyen
ce duel mains d'une main du temps humain
ne peut rien un supplice brand news voix
haute à ma tâche est fait apprécier sa
maison n'a pas fait un drôle de voir un
peu ce rôle ce manège est pas supposé se
rendre je rappelle que évidemment le
rôle ce que je tiens dans ma main droite
est disponible dans tous les débats de
fond sans a priori
filmant un peu ton briquet
[Musique]
je rappelle qu évidemment fumée
dangereux pour toute sorte de poumon
c'est légal alors donc cette séquence a
fait beaucoup parler est ce que vous
trouvez que cette polémique est normal
ce que vous aimez pas indécent et
déplacer grâce à james mais je suis
choquée parce que c'est une incitation à
la consommation
non seulement d'alcool de tabac et même
de substances illicites et remy des pros
il ya des pressions verbales de son côté
mais il ne veut même pas bonjour je suis
content d'être ici mis d'accord merci je
l'aimé pas vous dis là devant moi j'ai
23 ans je l'espère assez ouvert mais la
montre et des baidoa des jeunes de 12
ans ça le fait pas cela correct ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que mon dieu salvat
c'est un snap shatter c'est quelqu'un
qui ont considéré comme un humoriste
exactement donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
prendre avec ceux de la once et son fou
commerce et ne pouvaient pas venir sans
un joint en fait pour vous dire la
vérité parce que il en joue vachement
tout ça les regarde et vois que ça et
moi je kiffe skyrock en plus les quatre
carole pour faire bien leur boulot
oui c'est moi j'adore fred musa bien et
c'est un garçon vraiment formidable
simplement là je pense qu'il aurait dû
après au moins d amorcer la et dire
c'était voilà c'est plus du faux c'était
pour de valeur de faux et s'agissait
d'un sketch quoi voilà mais c'est
dommage
géraldine on adore la provocation à
l'épaule en droit de réponse quand ils
boivent et fument ils balancent les
cendrillons trouve ça génial quand rené
malleville fait la télé et qui sont tous
sans payer à marseille on trouve ça
formidable donc là pourquoi tout d'un
coup on sait exactement c'est vrai
[Rires]
mais non mais non mais t'as taddei est
pas méchant pourquoi tu dis ça parce que
quand vous parlez de foot après parfois
après quoi c'est parle de foot
ici par exemple quand camille combal
parle de vos émissions sur internet
c'est alors eh ben j'ai téléchargé les
faits vidéo qui passaient camier cohmad
en effet à 9 heures du matin mais on
avoir été déjà oui car alors on les fait
le lendemain des matches à 9 heures du
matin et tu crois quoi et c'est le man
who c'est l'homme de façon et balaban ya
aucune eau dégaine dame payer parce que
figure toi le fossé ils sont peu comme
ici c'est le gros crus et là mais je te
permet pas de parler de bon en tout cas
moi j'avais la passion a été sympa avec
toi moi j'avais l'impression qu'ils
avaient un côté justement très bonne
enfant gens venus 3e mi temps que j'ai
c'est un prestige chagall et voilà et
moi ça me plaît parce que j'ai un de
toulouse et ça me rappelle ma jeunesse
jean-luc j'ai envie d'avoir ton oui
alors mais sinon mais elle n'est pas
finie la france mais non mais c'est pas
alors il était d'accord avec malaysia
les contextualiser la vanne en fait
voilà à jean luc ch et embêté parce que
il ya ni l'un ni l'autre c'est vrai que
le problème c'est que mon train joints
comme ça et en plus c'est filmé puisque
maintenant la radio c'est aussi filmé
c'est pas bien après il y dit bien que
c'est dans tout l'état va donc il
sous-entend que c'est du tabac je trouve
que c'est beaucoup de bruit pour rien
c'est donc seul léger des ratios parce
que moi j'ai sursauté huda je vois ça je
trouve peu scandaleux parce que moi j'ai
des dames pas et moi à tout l'étagé
domino [ __ ] puis s'ils font du sport
je te vois une machette
[Applaudissements]
safra catz éviter pour les bobos ça
l'est toujours bien sûr c'est tellement
vulgariser débecte ou des spas léger
d'assaut moi je trouve ça scandaleux
on va voir ce qu'on pense des
téléspectateurs la polémique autour du
bénin j'aime j'aime pas 70% c'est un peu
gros voilà comme foyer il trouve que
c'est beaucoup de choses pour pas grand
chose